it's a Race Against Time to bring people
to safety the risk of drowning or being
swept away is very real
after months of drought torrential rains
devastated Emilia Romania a region
Northeast Italy
half a Year's worth of rain fell in just
36 hours
people here have never seen a disaster
on this scale
foreign
I was expecting the river to rise after
the Red Alert warning but instead of
breaking through in two or three places
it completely bursts its banks and the
water came with no warning
23 Rivers have overflown so far flooding
more than 40 municipalities and hundreds
of Roads more than 10 000 people have
had to leave their homes
those who stayed behind are picking up
the pieces
you see we need to do everything from
the beginning again the books all the
documents all the clothes they're all
gone they say we have to get out we have
to leave this house
and this formula one Grand Prix has been
canceled the track also submerged
organizers say they couldn't guarantee
the safety of attendees it's the second
time this month that people have died as
a result of extreme weather in Emilia
Romania
experts say climate change could make
them more frequent
disasters of today becoming tomorrow's
Facts of Life
in Northern Italy